hi there i guess it started i'll start
up my
uh microphone as well uh been packing
here to get ready to leave for uh
portugal and spain my trip
i wanted to do a video on the subject of
reading
it has come up on my blog it comes up
every now and again for a variety of
reasons
first of all reading is a very effective
way
to
improve your language skills in your own
language or in a foreign language
stephen krashen whom i often quote
believes that extensive silent reading
is the most powerful way to learn
a language or to improve in a language
i've had comments on my blog john
fatheringham for one igor the macedonian
with
all with slightly different perspectives
but nevertheless supporting the fact
that reading is
a very powerful way to include to
improve your language skills
now reading comes up as well uh not only
as part of language learning but as part
of the whole discussion about literacy
and i posted in a comment to my blog
some of the reports that are out there
saying that um you know 40 of the people
in
certainly in the united states or canada
and perhaps other industrialized nations
are functionally illiterate
uh
but a lot of this comes from the sort of
literacy advocate people and i'm very
skeptical about their numbers because i
think the whole issue of who is
functionally illiterate is really quite
subjective
and the numbers can vary from you know
30 to 40 to 50 percent and so forth it
doesn't really matter
the fact is that that there is a
perception
and we hear this from university
professors and others that the graduates
that they that are now entering
university read less and less well
now again it's common in human history
for the present generation to consider
that the young or the older generation
to consider that the younger generation
is no good and stuff so there's a little
bit of that certainly but let's assume
that we have a problem
and that it's difficult to measure the
problem and different people will try to
make uh you know different uh different
or
you know point out that the the the the
scope of the problem can can
sometimes be difficult to grab but the
problem is probably quite large and and
i i do believe that the more literate
you are
the better you use language the better
off you do
socially professionally and so forth in
our society now for some people that may
not matter there are many people who are
happily illiterate they have a job that
they can do
their loving family members have friends
and have a good time
but i i think for a lot of people
there
it's it is possible to trace a
correlation between low literacy
high unemployment levels high
incarceration rates
alcoholism you name it a lot of ills
seem to be attached with low literacy
levels so it's probably a good thing to
help people become better readers
now
i have mentioned before that i've been
on this
list serve put out by the national
institute for literacy or something and
and a lot of the literacy teachers are
more interested in social
uh change than they are in teaching
people how to read and and they're all
caught up in in the sort of
ideology of pedagogy in other words you
know literacy is a social construct and
really if someone can uh you know uh use
text to speech then we may be able to
finesse the whole literacy issue
altogether and it's just another way for
people with power in society to put
other people down and so
all these kind of irrelevant things
uh
i think the simple
uh
issue is that people do better in terms
of what most people want to achieve in
their lives they do better if they can
read well
i think that is probably true
so whose fault is it that so many people
seem to be unable to read and possibly
we have more people unable to read now
or to read well now than several
generations ago
uh it's certainly partly the
individual's fault and certainly to some
extent a factor of the family
environment it's certainly uh possibly
uh influenced by television and computer
games all of this is possible
but there's one thing to me that is
inescapable and that is that the schools
have the kids
for
you know five six hours a day
five days a week for 12 years
so
if kids graduate from high school and
cannot read there is no escaping the
responsibility of the school system
whatever other factors can and do
influence
how well someone reads
if i have someone in my charge
for 12 years
five hours a day five days a week and i
can also assign homework to that person
uh assign tasks to that person
watch what they're doing help them
correct them do whatever and at the end
of the day they can't read very well
that's my fault you can't escape the
responsibility of the school system and
i believe that the schools would be far
better off if they allowed people to sit
there and read silently
than do what they now do where teachers
just prattle on about all kinds of stuff
i remember that from my school
days uh i don't know what she or she is
saying half the time we're more focused
not fooling around
uh unless the teacher captures our
attention and our and our interest
uh they're entranced into various social
propagandas you know save the whales
uh you know mommy has two parents
they're both men or both women
uh any of these things which might be
wonderful causes to promote but
we shouldn't be promoting these kinds of
sort of
values however
wonderful the teacher thinks they are
if the kids can't read
and to get people to read let them read
things that they are interested in i
think that has to be
a major part of it and when i read on
these literacy list serves about
teachers who are going to impose this
poetry because they thought it's so
wonderful and then they're going to ask
the class
what they thought of it and whether they
can explain it and stuff and all of that
just
destroys reading and crashing has said
it that the sort of reading strategies
approach is leads to poorer reading
and if we can somehow provide kids with
reading opportunities provide them with
books encourage them let them read
all of this will should lead to better
reading
the other thing i wanted to let's see
what was there
the other issue with reading of course
in so far as language learning is
concerned is this debate about we've had
about graded readers
and igor in macedonia and i don't by the
way igor think that everybody in
macedonia is a shepherd
uh i don't think that you sit on the
hillside and blow and play your flute
while the sheep wander around otherwise
you wouldn't be on the internet
uh but he's a
a very strong crash tonight all you need
to is read and therefore graded readers
are very important
i believe that if you can
help grade the material for people
that's fine
and to some extent we do that at link
because we measure the unknown words we
measure you know difficulty based on
different criteria
but the main thing is the interest and
if a person is interested in the subject
they will fight their way through
difficult content and if the person is
not interested
it doesn't matter how simple the the
text is it's he's not communicating
because you have to engage the emotions
of the learner
and every time i have seen graded
readers which i found for russian you
know simple russian stories written by
someone about you know
sasha whose friend arrives from germany
and they visit leningrad and here's this
and that monument i have no interest in
that whatsoever no matter how
interesting they try to make it it's not
real it's not something that a russian
person wrote for a russian person so uh
yeah on the other hand as i've said we
now have the ability to record
conversations and then transcribe them
and they will tend to have less
difficulty in terms of vocabulary use
and so there are a number of strategies
that you can use in order to keep it
interesting and yet keep it accessible
to the learner graded readers as in the
penguin readers simplified versions of
robinson crusoe i've never been a fan of
but i have nothing against those and let
other people do them i prefer to have a
lot of new words and that's one of the
reasons we develop link so that you
don't have to look up every third word
it's almost there for you as you're
reading through it you have an
opportunity to work the words and
phrases and i do believe contrary to
crash that some degree of vocabulary
study i've said it 5 10 max no more than
that and some degree of output not
necessarily in the early stages but
later on
more and more output so you can
start to notice what you're missing
because
through your reading you get in a groove
you certain things you just don't notice
until you start to use the language and
then you make certain mistakes and now
you can start looking for those things
and you start to notice better so i've
rambled a bit on reading i'm going to
run out of time here i'm heading off to
portugal and spain we'll see if i can do
any more of these later on thank you for
listening bye for now